I could only imagine
the cocktail of garbage
inside your phone right
now, the lies you tell.
- Oh god, yeah.
- I just wanna apologize
to all those ladies.
You're the kind of guy, you
probably ask girls to marry you,
you're like, "I never say
this, I never say this,
"but I could legit see
myself marrying you.
"Could a guy like this break
your heart?"
And the answer is of course and
he will.
(rock music)
- What's up everybody?
Welcome to Stupid Questions
with Chris DiStefano.
I'm with Rachel Feinstein.
You can see her special
The Standups on Netflix
and she's got a good podcast
called 3 Girls, 1 Keith.
(rock music)
Alright, here's a stupid
question:
What's the dumbest lie you've
ever told your parents?
- Oh, here's a good one.
- Okay.
- My mom found like a hickey on
my neck,
just the biggest, dumbest--
- It was like obvious.
- And I told my mother that a
wolf bit me.
(both laughing)
- What, did your mom believe it?
- (laughs) No, she didn't.
She would always say
this when I lie to her,
she goes, "oh please,
Rachel, I lived in California
"in the 1960s, that's no wolf,
that's a goddamned hickey."
And she would go, "I've
been around the block,"
which is such a gross
thing to hear your mom say.
Like no one wants to
hear your mom be like,
"I've been passed around
a couple of times."
(rock music)
I have a stupid question for
you.
- Okay.
- Did you have a nickname
growing up?
- Well, when I was a kid,
people used to call me "Mayo."
- Were you fond of mayonnaise?
- Well, no, it's like I
was a basketball player
and I was like the only white
kid, so like my friends,
like my black friends
would call me "Mayo."
Oh, then they used to call me
"Gums,"
cause I was all gums, I had
really just,
I had like, I actually had
gingivitis,
like it was like a dental issue,
it's cause my gums were always
bleeding,
they'd be like "Chrissy
Gums" or like "Horse Face,"
something like that.
- Kids are so extremely cruel.
They'll find a thing you
weren't,
you never even occurred to
be self-conscious about,
like I still remember this guy,
like walking me home from school
one day,
he's like, "how come you've
got that little thing
"on the top of your thighs,
it's like extra fat."
(both laughing)
Who says that?
I've never forgot Wesley's
dumb sentence for the,
you know, still now, when
I look in the mirror,
I'm like, "ah, that little extra
fat
"that Wesley didn't care for."
- Little cherry of fat on top.
- And also, who insults someone
and then makes them answer for
it?
He's like, "how come you got
that?"
- Yeah, yeah.
(rock music)
- Next stupid question:
What's the weirdest thing you've
seen
in somebody else's home?
- Well, my friend that I grew up
with,
her dad had a toothpick
dispenser next to his uh,
couch and sometimes he
wouldn't be able to find
his toothpicks when I'd go
over there and he would go,
"where the hell's my 'spencer?
"Where in the hell's my
'spencer?"
That's all he wanted,
he just wanted his toothpick
dispenser.
- Now, would that, as a young
woman,
make you feel extremely
uncomfortable to be
alone in the house with that
father?
- I remember one time, he
was on his way to 7-11,
and he goes, "you girls want
anything?"
It was just me and my
friend and I was like,
"no, I'm okay," and he
goes, "I'm just gonna get me
"a hooker and a hotdog" (both
laughing).
It was an interesting
thing to choose to tell
like a couple of 10 year olds.
- A hooker and a hotdog.
That's a good t-shirt,
Hooker and a Hotdog.
(rock music)
Next stupid question:
chunky heels or chunky guys?
- I like a chunky guy.
- Nice.
- Yes, I like a little extra
weight,
I like a little thickness in a
man.
- Yeah, well, your fiance's
a little thick guy.
- Yeah, I like em thick.
- He's in shape, though.
- I like to see a thick thigh on
a man,
because I don't wanna be the
bigger one.
I don't wanna be like Big
Rach kinda lumbering over
and if a guy's a little out of
shape,
I feel like that makes me
feel more confident, too.
I wanna bring like the
treats to the hookup.
- Yeah, I got like, I
got some weight on me,
like to go in the pool, I
keep my shirt on, you know?
Just have my tits get
wet, you know (laughs)?
- I heard you have
beautiful, natural breasts.
- Oh, my god, who told you that?
- People pay a lot of money
for tits like yours, right?
- Hell yeah.
(rock music)
Alright, thank you so much
for being a part of the show.
Did you have a good time?
- I did, I did.
- Alright, so you know, for
being a part of my show,
I wanted to give you a stupid
gift.
- Thank you.
- Yes.
I wanted to give you this.
- Aww.
- And these are just
aqua jewelry, like your mother
wears.
(Rachel laughing loudly)
We just thought these
would be good for you.
- God, I'm gonna get laid,
I'm gonna get laid.
- Laid, woo!
- I got a good feeling.
You know what, I'm worth it.
- Yeah.
- I'm worth it.
- So, thank you for
watching Stupid Questions
with Chris DiStefano, my
daughter, Rachel Feinstein.
- Oh my god.
- Stupid Questions.
- Uglier than anything I've ever
seen.
(rock music)